[Musique]
il avait aussi j'appelle débat monsieur
s'écoute voyage annonce le 34e rue du
chemin vert
c'est entendu merci mademoiselle
une belle journée aujourd'hui n'est-ce
pas
hier c'était plutôt mouillé
qui sera avec l'arrêt de métro ça tombe
bien dans tous ces cas là vous savez
quand il ya grève serrures que les taxis
ne travaille pas
ah c'est pas drôle pour l'usager comme
bien des groupes comme ça
différences de température c'est ce qui
amène beaucoup de grip
voici monsieur pardon non si bien
monsieur c'est laborieux pour arriver à
cette guerre n'est ce pas madame oui
jean d'auguste
mais atteint bus sont pris d'assaut
quartier saint nazaire vraiment on ne
peut pas dire que c'est un quartier
désert
on dirait que tous ces gens prennent la
chose avec philosophie avec bonne humeur
même nom bateau
j'aime tellement réjoui non
aujourd'hui
les malheureux
pour moi c'est terminé ah oui madame
nous sommes presque arrivés je fais ton
courage aux autres je vous remercie et à
vous aussi vaste c'est pas terminé bon
bah non il faut avouer qu'il en faut
vous savez moi je sais pas tous les
jours quand même non savoie combiné
messieurs alors s'appuyer 7 francs 30 me
donne on va essayer de vous en donner
madame alors rue saint philippe du roule
oui s'il vous plaît bien
belle journée pour un jour de grève
n'est ce pas oui beaucoup de monde
je vois que vous êtes un taux chinois et
vietnamiens du nord exactement vietnam
vient du nord ah oui vous êtes à paris
comme étudiante sans doute non je
travaille dans les décors hausse tout au
moins dans l'ameublement moderne
ah oui quand ce sera bien oui c'est bien
cette année c'est un métier d'avenir
oui la décoration est en effet une
profession très très variés
nous voici devant le théâtre de l'odéon
garde de france
vous y avez déjà été oui parce que j'ai
mon père mon beau père qui travaillait
là oui c'est loisir très bien j'ai même
eu des prix en fin d'année tout au moins
cadeau de fin d'année
ar mais c'est pas bien
oui c'est un théâtre qui est très réputé
mais je ne me pensais théâtre non que
muet dans des petits théâtres
oui je suis toute petite pièce de mais
intéressante qu'on intéressant
mais le plus le tertre est petit plus
l'ambiance doit être sèche à millières
c'est ça c'est cela oui
ça fait bien longtemps ouais je n'ai pas
été au théâtre alors vous devez 5 francs
70 pardon merci
oui
ça
les 4 au 10 je suis madame
pardon là
c'est bien madame
oui madame
écoutez madame j'aurais bien reculer il
y avait des voitures derrière sur le
moment non merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est amusant petit petit
alors chers amis la journée aujourd'hui
mois dans l'après-midi bras bref quand
même super 5 6 heures la paire saint
nazaire l'opéra de l'amandier morceau de
pain qui est fait c'est parce que j'ai
faim alors on y mange toujours aussi
bien aux royals les jours
oui mais comment tout ça y est la reine
pédauque c'est mieux ben oui mais c'est
toujours pareil centre exemple venir
adressant cette conversation vous allez
vous mademoiselle hobos palladium s'il
vous plaît aux petites balades bien à
votre service vous êtes étrangères
d'être ce prix je pense que votre maison
italienne
non oui c'est vrai a oui voyez vous on
ne nous est dit que les italiens accents
presque comme les
et france quand il parvient pas comme
nous la naksa parce que comme les
français français du sud
oui c'est comme ça que nous sommes à peu
près de la même race la race humaine
paris vous plaît oui vous attend chanter
oui oui eh bien ça fait toujours plaisir
j'ai un coeur de paris dans tous les
magasins seulement ici il ya un monde si
si si vous aviez vous comprenez on voit
les noirs et les blancs ça c était ça
j'aimerais savoir s'il ya beaucoup de
chapeaux nice et des cliniques des
chinois chinoise
il te ligne à pain ils sont rentrés
sains nous pour la peau pour ce qu'ils
peuvent
c'est pour ceux comme il vit l'alma à
paris et la capitale internationale la
capitale de la liberté parce que j'ai vu
beaucoup de gens je sais quand on dit
aux français mais enfin une femme
blanche avec noir ou bien le contraire
vous savez vous savez mademoiselle tout
cela est une affaire de goût personnel
auquel il est très difficile de répondre
je pense que tous les goûts sont dans la
nature parce que indiqué à paris des
noirs vivaient mieux mieux mieux créer
dans les allées nous arbib absolument
comme nous ils ont les mêmes droits
oui il faut aller dans une finale les
échos dans les cours dans les écoles et
les universités et on débourse choses et
je cherchais
et je raconte un noir qui était bien
habillé comme ça et je lui demandais où
est-ce qu'elle a sorti la petite romane
au moi je suis resté conseil jeudi alors
ça veut dire qu'ils ont quelque chose
contre les blancs parce que parce que
les blancs fait l'udc en lice y ait
quelque chose peut-être pas mais comment
il m'a répondu qu'on ne veut pas le
faire
mais vous savez c'est très difficile de
répondre sur des questions comme ça
parce que ce n'est pas la généralité
c'est des questions qui sont peut-être
persil ciselé assez isolé et c'est
difficile de répondre sur un cas isolé
en voulant parler de tout le monde
peut-être êtes-vous tombé sur un garçon
ce soir là qui étaient de mauvaise
humeur qui était et qui avec une
contrario pieds et peut être qui s'ils
étaient blancs ils me répondent du pad
même comme ça le coach alain je crois
qu'il s'est fait comme ça aux français
pour un couple et d'infériorité
peut-être un petit complexe peut-être
pas puis j'ai entendu que z c'est mais
enfin vous savez je la pire marée pas il
faut être sûr de ces choses là
alors où allez vous monsieur vient vous
demander ce centre et michel-ange dans
le 16e arrondissement 63 michel-ange
bien
ça se trouve le site pourrait bien sûr
monsieur bien faire monsieur la rue
michel-ange largue d'attrayant pêche à
lille ce soir
oui très éclairé quand on n'est pas un
samedi ou un dimanche on est en pleine
semaine comment que ça se fait ça vous
avez des têtes parce que ses joueurs
[Musique]
où allez vous s'il vous plaît vous
hennequin je me souviens plus numéro je
crois c'est tout 55 bien
enfin bon ce soir n'est ce pas
vous prenez souvent le taxi comme ça
vous avez bien de la chance je vois que
vous avez une petite mini jupe ravissant
diminue des mini d'ailleurs oui oui
c'est ce que j'ai vu lorsque vous êtes
arrivé
c'est assez à la mode en ce moment il
faut être jeune quand même pour porter
ce genre de de jute évidemment
je m' a très mal une femme de 40 ans
quand en 2 min
évidemment ça sera plutôt un peu osé
si les bienfaits tant qu'enseignant
enfin j'estime que pour une jeune fille
évidemment c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
du tout j'aime j'adore
qu'est ce que vous faites de beaux à
paris vous êtes dans la couture non si
les regards
c'est ariane avait appris mais
évidemment c'est une profession qui
nécessitent assez de deux nouveautés
dans les tenues il faut se tenir à la
mode
eh bien ça vous va pas mal voyez vous
alors mon chéri la cale que tu veux que
je te jure bon je vais te la jouer et
après tu es monté bien je vais
travailler mon cas vous et après ce sera
tout
[Musique]
ma venue